let's talk about why we're washing our
hands right how many and if you cook and
I like to make my grilled cheese with
like a lot of butter in the pan and so
it ends up my pan after I eat my grilled
cheese my pan is full of like butter and
grease right does anybody does anybody
feel seeing that before like a pan is
like really greasy from like cooking
food well if I were to take that pan and
run it under water um would it clean the
pan just plain water what do you think
no right you can't just take a bunch of
grease on a pan and put it under water
and expect it to be clean you have to
add something what you have to add it's
um something sort of so natural right
and that's because the molecules inside
and flutter like it's a special special
kind of fat right they're actually the
same type of molecules that surround the
coronavirus and so if we see that our
soap is dissolving all of the fat inside
of our pan and making our pans clean
then it makes a lot of sense that soap
can also dissolve the fat that surrounds
the coronavirus to get the coronavirus
sort of like off of your off of your
hands so that's a really good we always
need to wash our hands I know I have to
use lotion now because my hands are so
dry because I'm always washing my hands
and so that's really really important